was genau ist ein triftiger grund und
was muss sich der polizei denn wenn ich
kontrolliert werde vorlegen das
besprechen wir jetzt mit dem anwalt an
kempkens der uns zugeschaltet ist guten
abend herr kempkens ja was ist ein
triftiger grund und was muss ich dabei
haben wenn die polizei mich kontrolliert
also es ist gar nicht so leicht zu
beantworten
ich habe auch erst mal in den duden
geguckt in dieser begriff triftiger
grund der gibt's schon in bayern im
zusammenhang so ein bisschen mit den
ausgangs beschränkungen auch abends und
na ja das ist ja sehr schwammig denn
triftig ist ja für einen so und so aber
trifft trifft dich ist auf jeden fall
einen schwerwiegenden grund das bezieht
sich natürlich auf alles was man so
machen muss also sprich versorgungs
gänge die ich jetzt nicht innerhalb
dieses 15 kilometer radius mache ich
darf aber auch familie besucht dass es
auch erlaubt oder ein lebenspartner
besuchen und ich darf beispielsweise
alte pflegen die außerhalb dieses radius
wohnen oder beispielsweise bei die nicht
zusammenleben sondern wo die kinder in
anderen haushalten leben da darf ich
beispielsweise auch das sorgerecht
ausüben das geht also auch über 15
kilometer hinaus also man braucht schon
ein wirklich triftigen grund lassen sie
uns da mal ein bisschen ins detail gehen
was ist etwa mit menschen die ja
besorgungen oder einkäufe für andere
familienmitglieder erledigen wollen
das ist okay aber man muss natürlich
sagen dieser dieser dieser 15 kilometer
radius triftiger grund wenn ich also
sagen wir mal nebenan ein supermarkt
habe wo ich kaufte einkaufen könnte dann
wird es natürlich schwer zu sagen dass
ich den aufsuchen der 20 kilometer
entfernt ist das wäre nicht in ordnung
denn das wäre kein triftiger grund es
geht ja immer um die frage kann ich die
besorgung die ich machen muss innerhalb
meiner stadt machen oder innerhalb
dieses 15 kilometer radius drumherum
oder eben nicht und nur wenn ich das
eben nicht kann dann darf ich diesen
radius überschreiten
hier lassen sie es auch darüber sprechen
was ich dabei haben muss wie ich etwa
einen triftigen grund nachweisen kann
oft ist das ja gar nicht möglich lassen
sie uns über etwas reden was am
wenigsten belegbar ist die liebe zum
beispiel was ist mit menschen die eine
fernbeziehung führen nicht verheiratet
sind wenn einer oder vielleicht sogar
beide aus dem risikogebiet kommen dürfen
die sich denn erst gar nicht mehr sehen
doch das wäre auch so ein triftiger
grund wenn ich so eine schnell eine
lebenspartnerschaft oder so eine
beziehung aufrechterhalten will das ist
mit sicherheit so ein triftiger grund
aber es wird natürlich etwas schwerer
nachzuweisen
wenn ich in so eine polizeikontrolle
komme das sagen wir anwälte immer sagt
bloß nichts also keine aussage machen
denn da kann man sich hinterher immer
noch zu äußern das gilt quasi auch bei
solchen kontrollen man muss nicht
unbedingt was sagen man kann aber auch
und das macht auch durchaus sinn muss
man ehrlicherweise sagen denn wenn ich
jetzt nichts sage da ist ja erstmal der
verstoß ist ja festgestellt wenn ich
also jetzt von meinem wohnort eben 15
ich sag mal 30 kilometer entfernt
angetroffen werden dann haben wir ja den
verstoß und dann muss ich ja nachweisen
dass ich da berechtigt war also die
nachweispflicht die darlegungs licht
nicht immer beim betroffenen und wenn
man vor ort sofort eine schlüssige
geschichte erzählt die polizisten auch
glauben die ordnungsbehörden die das
eben kontrollieren dann wird sicherlich
kein verfahren eingeleitet wenn man aber
gar nichts sagt wird ein verfahren
eingeleitet dann kann man sich später im
verfahren noch dazu äußern ist prozessor
auch kein problem also lieber alles gut
vorbereiten viele von uns sie dass sie
an diesen zeiten auch einfach mal raus
in die natur man möchte einfach einen
ausflug machen weil einem zu hause die
decke auf den kopf fällt
ich nehme an das ist kein triftiger
grund ja also das ist das ist
tatsächlich schwer denn nur raus zu
gehen das wird mit sicherheit ja auch in
den eigenen im eigenen bereich gehen
dann ist ja immer der wohnort plus 15
kilometer um den wohnort das ist ja kein
zirkelschluss um die wohnung selber
sondern um den wohnort in dem bund
länder besteht ja darin wohnort und da
müsst ihr vielleicht wirklich mal sehen
wie das jetzt ganz konkret umgesetzt
wird aber das jetzige verständnis ist
eigentlich das ist eben 15 kilometer um
den ort sind das heißt ich darf mich in
meiner gemeinde bewegen kann also alle
behördengänge machen alle arztbesuche in
der regel auch supermärkte besucher denn
den meisten städten gibt es ja
supermärkte und dann kommen noch diese
15 kilometer darum darüber hinaus wenn
ich jetzt ein spaziergang mache in einem
ja in einem in einem wald der 30
kilometer entfernt ist dann wird es
eigentlich schon schwierig denn in
diesen 15 kilometer zone in der ich mich
ja bewegen darf ist in aller regel auch
ein kleiner wald
viele menschen haben vielleicht ein
kleines ferienhaus oder eine
ferienwohnung vielleicht oder in einem
anderen bundesland und decken sich jetzt
ha da werde ich doch weiterhin hin
reisen dürfen ist ja mainz ist gemietet
oder gekauft ist ja mein zweites zuhause
ist das okay ja das ist auch ein
triftiger grund wenn man beispielsweise
eine mir eine wohnung oder eine
ferienwohnung oder ein haus oder so wenn
man das kontrollieren muss ob da alles
in ordnung ist ob da vielleicht
irgendwelche probleme gibt dann muss man
natürlich hin das ist ja ein triftiger
grund das ist ja sozusagen auch eine
kollidierende pflicht denn es gibt ja
eine ganze reihe an pflichten die man
auch hat dass man beispielsweise tiere
versorgen muss die vielleicht in meinem
stall 20 30 kilometer entfernt stehen
das ist ja ohne weiteres möglich oder
eben auch eine wohnung die man natürlich
ab und zu besichtigen muss ob da noch
alles in ordnung ist das ist ja auch
eine verpflichtung denn man muss ja auch
schäden fernhalten die ausgehen können
von solchen wohnung für andere person
also muss man kontrollieren nennt sich
verkehrssicherheitspflicht und dann darf
man diese grenze überschreiten das ist
auf jeden fall ein triftiger grund und
wenn ich eine wohnung aufsuchen will aus
privaten kunden beispielsweise ist das
sicherlich auch ein triftiger grund aber
ich muss natürlich die anderen
regelungen einhalten wenn es da
beispielsweise irgendwelche ich sag mal
beherbergungs aufenthaltsverbote oder
etwas anderes regional gibt das muss ich
natürlich zusätzlich beachten also keine
einfache sache triftige gründe gibt es
viele diese nachzuweisen nicht immer
einfach
die campions vielen herzlichen dank für
das gespräch mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schau dich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren